I'm now being joined by a Latin Grammy
ambassador miss Sophia Carson hello
there how are you you look gorgeous look
at this hot pink I mean I wish let me
grab the other end you got to bring the
drama to the land grant I have to write
we have to always was it me to be here
you're presenting and you're also an
ambassador for the Latin Grammys I mean
how exciting it's so thrilling it's such
an honor to be here you know celebrating
Latin music and being an ambassador for
the foundation is really truly I'm just
incredible so happy to be here we see
they're celebrating 20 years of Latin
Grammys and I think you know better than
anybody there they're pulling all the
stops there's a whole lot of stars and a
lot of icons here tonight who you hoping
to rub elbows with and Ricky who's a
dear friend of mine and my families and
I just saw him on the carpet and he's
hosting tonight and performing and
premiering a song which I'm dying to
hear so much an icon so I just adore him
but so many so many incredible artists
tonight imagine as an artist I mean
you're probably just like beaming and
you're so influenced by all of these
stars I want to talk about your music
though because you released a new single
gray area what does that song mean to
you and and would it mean to share it
with the world you know it's always so
exciting and such an intimate thing to
share a song with the world
I loved collaborating with gray I'm such
a fan of their work you know
three-time Grammy nominees that was like
so honored to be able to collaborate
with them on this record this record we
just shot the music video for which will
be coming up very soon but it's about
you know when you're in love but you're
in that area where you don't know if
they feel the way that you feel and it's
kind of this like you know this is what
you have to decide what they're gonna
say and in this or run the other way and
it's you know that difficult gray area
but I'm happy to share it with the world
so special and also you're so busy like
you're such a triple threat and you know
we actually had dove Cameron on et
recently and we asked her the
possibility of another installment of
descendents and she didn't rule it out
but should it would be difficult without
Cameron what do you think it'll take for
you do you guys think there's more life
for the descendents
you know the descendents franchise
changed all of our lives I don't think
any of us could imagine it without
Cameron it's a difficult subject but um
who knows when it's the future holds who
knows what the future holds would you be
open to the possibility of maybe
continuing ivv
I love Eevee I love Eevee two powerhouse
Latinas are headlining the Super Bowl
halftime show JLo and shaquita how
excited are you for that performance I
feel like it's a major major moment oh
my gosh it's about time two women and
two Hispanic women who are you know on
top of the world and they really you
know we're Trailblazers for women
everywhere in this industry so it's it's
spectacular headlining the Superbowl
it's amazing you're in for amazing night
I don't think I've got the designer who
you wearing John Bautista Valley odd
Koontz were come through have so much
fun so much
[Music]